on paperwork when not if but when you  win big at a casino a new bill in  congress would increase how much you can  win before you actually have to report  it for taxes and so forth it's a  bipartisan act called the slot act and  it would increase the limit to 5 000  right now it's twelve hundred dollars  and it's been that way since nineteen  seventy seven nevada congresswoman dina  titus is supportive of this of course  and she says the number of jackpots that  hit that threshold that's in place now  well it's increased dramatically because  of inflation she believes it's an  unnecessary burden on the gaming  industry and i guess sharia burden if  you win a lot of money too i guess so  man there's just an array of slot  machines there that was